ce n'est plus chahut c'est le chaos
c'était plus le débat c'est la violence
par des injures d'une de mes collègues
je le redis aujourd'hui la France
insoumise est un obstacle au débat
démocratique moi je veux bien qu'on me
dise que on ralentit le débat mais on a
proposé d'ouvrir samedi et dimanche
comme on proposera probablement d'ouvrir
samedi et dimanche prochain si vous
aviez voulu améliorer l'emploi des
seniors de manière juste déjà vous
seriez venu travailler ce week-end on
aurait ouvert l'assemblée plutôt que de
vous prélasser à la maison dans la
partie LFI on est vraiment dans
l'insoumission permanente donc on
cherche à bordéliser parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière et de faire feu de tout bois
pour essayer de créer des incidents de
séance
confortable vous ne servez strictement à
rien les Français ne sont pas dupe de
votre perfidie lundi vous m'avez dit
tais-toi la vieille depuis une semaine
nous sommes face à une obstruction
systématique des de la collision autour
de la France insoumise avec soit des
amendements de suppression alinéa par
alinéa soit des amendements qui sont des
amendes de pure obstruction consistant à
supprimer la disposition technique la
une autre sans jamais en parler mais
simplement pour ralentir les débats voir
des provocations donc vous ne pouvez pas
arriver ici et me dire que la
suppression des CHSCT n'a eu aucun effet
ce sont 150 orphelins doivent veuves en
plus et vous avez la responsabilité de
ses choix politiques vous êtes un
imposteur et un assassin si on pouvait
se rappeler juste une chose c'est qu'en
politique on n'a pas d'ennemis on a des
adversaires et bien on éviterait d'en
arriver à de telles extrémités j'espère
qu'évidemment des excuses claires et
sincères seront présentées mais vous
savez pas des excuses je m'excuse mais
non des excuses point barre français
vont pas donner les clés du pays demain
à des excités à des gens qui insultent
tout le monde et qui veulent couper des
têtes j'ai eu il y a quelques instants à
ce micro des mots que l'émotion et
l'emportement
m'ont fait mal choisi et qui sont
déplacés je souhaite évidemment les
retirer et adresser des excuses
publiques au ministre ça veut dire quoi
à l'arrêt
c'est que le moins de personnes
travaillent mais partout ça veut dire à
l'arrêt dans les transports ça veut dire
dans les arrêts dans les dans les
entreprises dans les magasins les grands
magasins les supermarché partout partout
c'est un mot d'ordre qui parfois un peu
surprenant nous avons toujours considéré
que le propre de la démocratie sociale
le prof de la démocratie tout court
c'est que les désaccords puissent
s'exprimer que les opinions puissent
s'exprimer sans qu'il y ait de blocage
j'entends vos excuses mais vous
comprendrez qu'à traiter d'assassin de
se pardonne pas par contre ces excuses
ont émérite c'est qu'elle permet au
débattre continuer et c'est mon seul
souhait trois jours après le terrible
accident de voiture implique en pierre
Palmade le ministère de lance un appel
aux deux passagers de l'humoriste il
nous manque ces deux personnes et il
faut effectivement qu'on puisse les
entendre pour vraiment reconstituer les
faits donc bien sûr je les appelle à se
rendre dans n'importe quel commissariat
obrigades de gendarmerie pour expliquer
les faits
je crois qu'en effet professionnellement
ce sera très très difficile pour lui
la question est-elle là parce que ce qui
va être aussi très difficile pour lui
c'est de dormir tout simplement comme
vous le savez quand vous avez commis une
mauvaise action même sans le vouloir ça
peut très bien ça peut l'emmener sur une
espèce d'issue fatale pour lui-même ça
peut le Christ Rédempteur frappé par la
foudre cette photo impressionnante a été
prise vendredi dernier à 18h55 précise
un nouvel objet volant a été abattu hier
par l'armée américaine c'est le
quatrième en moins de 10 jours il s'agit
cette fois d'un objet octogonale qui
volait à environ 6000 mètres d'altitude
dans l'État du Michigan avec un
paratonnerre sur la tête le Christ de 30
mètres de haut et souvent frappé par la
poudre environ 5 fois par an cette fois
le phénomène a été photographié comment
ne pas être impressionné
par cette météorite qui a transpercé le
ciel cette nuit quelques secondes de
merveilleux capter dans la partie nord
de la France
l'astéroïde a été analysé et identifié
comme nom dangereux les fragments sont
tombés dans la Manche mais la protection
civile néanmoins été prévenue